so you talked about working in the
social welfare system and
obviously in the 1960s there was a real
push for a sort of
racial reparation via social welfare
programs and the great society programs
the idea expressed by lbj is that well
now the the sort of barriers had been
removed
uh if you had all of the runners at the
start line and one of the runners was 20
yards behind the start line that somehow
we had to find a way to get the person
20 yards behind the start line up to the
start line that's what the social
welfare programs
were for uh but it seems like in many
ways the social welfare programs
actually inhibited the ability for that
runner to ever
catch up and there have been a lot of
minority groups in the united states who
have started off 20 yards behind the
start line compared to white america
many of those minority groups now
routinely outperform white americans in
terms of income
including many groups of african
immigrants nigerian americans for
example outperform
white americans in terms of income so
maybe you can talk a little bit about
social welfare programs
were they was just well-intentioned it
went wrong or
was it what exactly happened with the
social welfare programs why didn't it
help achieve this
very specifically what happened was
because whites were
longing for their innocence what whites
did was
literally steal away from black people
agency over their own fate
over their own lives lbj said
put your life in my hands
i will give you an upward bound program
i will expand
welfare payments i will have school
busing i will have public housing
on and on i am the actor
i am the agent of your uplift of your
fate not you you are nothing but
a sort of uh cipher
for uh my innocence
we we blacks hitting not quite knowing
how to handle freedom yet
bought into that and sold our soul
away we put agency we said okay
you be the agent of my uplift
you you're right you did commit you were
ugly you were racist so forth so now you
can redeem yourself by uplifting me
well when you look at that you're giving
away
agency to your own uplift you're putting
it in somebody else's hands
when in all of human history has that
ever worked
you don't give up agency and then think
you're going to somehow miraculously get
get ahead you want agency you we here's
what we should have said
we should have said to white american to
lyndon johnson
thank you but no thanks you worry about
your innocence
we'll worry about our development we'll
focus as individuals
we will become better educated we will
out compete you
we don't want your help we have our own
honor
our own sense of dignity our own
self-possession
we fail to do that uh the end of
many many many many many and i mean many
individual blacks did
do that and they are doing their
thriving
today and we see them everywhere in
every walk of life making the point that
if one wants to really take charge of
one's fate
and move ahead you're free to do that
today in america you can become
literally the president
if that's what you want to do you can
become the ceo of a major corporation
you can become an artist you can become
a veterinarian you can do whatever you
want
uh and the government will will never
ever under any circumstances be able to
to do that for you that's a it's a it's
a uh
a kind of sick again symbiotic
bond between that that came out of this
great confession
uh in in the 60s and and both groups got
blinded and made a very a quick down and
dirty deal that's why i think of lyndon
johnson's
great society as a down and dirty deal
he said basically i need the uh
i need the the innocence to to uh
to have legitimacy as the president and
keep legit keep the government
legitimate and so forth i need that
so i don't i'm gonna give you all these
programs even though
they don't do anything whatsoever but
but
teach you corruption embroil you in
corruption
i worked in those programs for three
years
i've never seen so much corruption in my
life it was just wide open
you have to fight for your life i had to
get out of there
or sink into that uh
and i was lucky i was very lucky i had
two good parents and
talked a lot and finally found my way uh
out
of there um yeah
but that's what we we we now have to do
we have to get away from that
we have to get away from our symbiotic
relationship to white people
uh i don't want to have a any i want to
be a human being
i want to be a citizen of the united
states i want to relate to all
other human citizens what your race is
i don't care did you know that every
like on this video creates one
additional glorious leftist here don't
ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity just hit the like button